[Music]
hello
and welcome to round four here at the
tata steel
chess tournament it is early in
charlotte
dania how is that coffee well it's early
for chess players i
realized to my [__] that's actually tea
i've uh traded in
but i've resigned the game um made some
loose leaf tea but
uh you know the games never failed to
wake me up it's like the strongest
cup of coffee anywhere all i need is a
couple of night orbs fiona
all i need is uh round four of tata
steel if only around four had just begun
oh wait a minute
it has i can't wait to jump into the
action fiona thank you
everybody for joining i am super excited
for another day
packed with fun matchups and fun action
absolutely let's hope the players are in
a fighting mood today
and let's remind everyone already
tomorrow is a rest day
so often the players you know they give
it their all tomorrow they can rest
all they want but before we go to the
games let's have a very quick look
at the results from yesterday
so yesterday we had two decisive uh
results the first
decisive game of the day was hari
krishna taking down
the leader niels grandelius and then the
second one was actually the last game of
the day to finish
kept us here till late at night ali
rizza fuja playing a positional
masterpiece
uh to beat the winner of last year's
challengers group david anton
indeed and yesterday was equally defined
by the non-decisive matchups of course
arientari
drawing uh his compatriot one magnus
carlson relatively unknown player
um that was a big result for aryan
particularly with the black pieces
drawing an end game where
you know magnus was renowned for his
ability to squeeze those end games and
uh really the heartbreaker uh fabi
playing a an absolutely spectacular
tactical game against jan shistop duda
uh really just a phenomenal calculation
throughout the whole game but
young's just uh incredible calculation
to
save the game in time pressure fabi was
winning at one point
didn't drive it all the way home all of
them are going all of these players are
going to be hungry
uh to continue their good play this
round
yeah and with uh fabiano and magnus
failing to capitalize on those white
pieces that means that we now have a big
tie
in the lead of the tournament let's
bring up the pairing so a five-way tie
at the top with harry krishna magnus
carlsen
anish kiwi fabiano caruana and niels
grandelius on two
out of three indeed it is a log
jam at the top and uh definitely the
leaders will be defined
at the end of this round coming into
rest day number one i'm pretty sure that
we'll see a more well-defined group of
leaders
and um we've got some mouth-watering
matchups today fiona
absolutely let's bring up our favorites
the
boxing like head-to-head
even there you can always like feel some
of them look
friendly others look like yeah i'm gonna
crush yourself
oh yeah i'm coming to this tournament
i'm scoring some points
but i think they're all thinking that
but they're all going to score some
points there are
they all already have everyone's already
have yeah i mean i
we said it yesterday i think it's really
great to have nobody on zero out of
three
um because we've mentioned it so many
times and here
well the last match-up of the day
probably the main one
and here we have the pairings one more
time giving us a bit more time
to uh to discuss them the last one there
was jordan van ferece the local the
local hero
uh taking on magnus carlsen what is
really intimidating
it's like particularly intimidating he
really does
yeah i mean jordan i don't think jordan
is going to be looking at that
that boxing video before the round i
think he's jumping he's more intimidated
by magnus's opening repertoire but
jordan has shown his ability time and
time again
to compete on equal terms with the top
of the top
yeah he's so far undefeated uh this year
and today with
with the white pieces i think he'll be
look well we'll get to the games in a
second but i
i expect jordan to be looking at to be
looking for a fight
today against the world champion what
else do we have
one match-up is between two players from
our leaders group it's
pantala hari krishna against fabiano
carrana
how do you think fabiano is going to
feel after the missed opportunity
from yesterday fabi is a very objective
player i think he
you know he doesn't really tilt that
easily um and that's one thing that's
always impressed
uh impressed me about him is the fact
that he
you know he can have a disappointing
result and then come in the next game
and
and make a very solid draw and harry
kreshna is playing with the white pieces
so papi is going to play for a win
he's going to use his chances but he's
not going to play you know e4b5 or
he's not going to go crazy he's going to
play what he would play win
lose or draw in the previous round well
shall we
uh we can discuss the the remaining
pairings as we get to the game
shall we see actually maybe start with
fabiano c
and confirm that he hasn't opened with
one b5
yeah well he i believe has played b5
yeah he has but it wasn't on move one it
was a move five actually
uh it was a rylo lopez which you know
really needs no introduction nor
explanation
um actually would you agree we have seen
very few have we even seen a single ray
lopez yes
i mean i i'm trying to scratch my memory
i mean i
really don't don't remember a single one
i think we haven't had a single one
that's actually quite that's actually
quite crazy i mean
it's it's such a common opening have we
even had we didn't have a berlin
that's crazy i mean you can remember how
many berlins you would have like even a
year or two ago i think there
has been this we just had very few e45s
we had a
one italian we had one petrov but very
literally 45 action
yeah that is just quite crazy i mean
yeah wow but anyways we did have a uh a
rye lopez here
and um uh fabio responding would be with
the i believe this is called
this is actually embarrassing i think
this is the archangel bishop c5 i just
know this is the bishop c5 variation
and uh you know people who know their
lopez would know that bishop b7 is the
sort of traditional mainline
and um after rookie one b5 bishop b3
black can play d6 or
black can play the marshall attack which
was castle c3 d5 that's a gambit
uh but not to delve too deeply into
these sidelines bishop c5 is a very
popular sideline
among all levels and
hari grisham responding with a4 very
typical move opening up the queen side
and then occupying the center
and now just move a5
and
and after a5 the whole idea is that
you know black takes on eight pilots to
the knights then this e5 pawn and that's
the
classic rye lopez upon the c5 is going
to fall so that pawn on a5 i believe is
basically untouchable fabi drops his
bishop back
hari krishna stops fabi from developing
his bishop to g4
and so papi says all right i'll be in
keto i still think this is
well within uh the range of theory i'm
quite sure this has arisen many many
times fiona uh really the accident is
yet to come here
but bishop c5 usually an indicator that
black you know
wants some active play and uh
is uh looking for for a very fighting
game here today
yeah no absolutely and and uh you know
this line bishop c5
is it's not the kind of line you place
it's not like the berlin
there's no force draw against it and you
play it if you want a good combative
game
it is dangerous in the sense that it
requires
knowledge of a lot of theory um but fabi
is
very well known for his incredible
opening preparation and has been known
for that for many years
yeah actually speaking of uh well he's
been working for a number of years with
rustam kansemjanov and i actually just
saw rustam for the first time here today
in vik just 10 minutes ago
because today it is the day before the
rest day so it's the day
where everyone has to uh to go for their
second covet tests
and i think uh i think fabiano had said
on the opening you know muslim
on principle one come to the playing
hall he'll just you know stay in the
room
uh in these covert times but today he
made he made a rare appearance here
uh the the track down well i have a joke
i have an early morning joke for you
fiona
uh what did cousin jonno help fabie do
um after fabi didn't play chess right
here
shake off the roost the rooster
maybe we could work on delivery yeah no
i mean
it was so funny that i needed to like
understand it because i knew people
would basically die laughing
but it's something at least i mean it's
8 13 a.m
who can really make jokes at 8 13 a.m
but anyways back to the position what is
white's main move here
um i'm pretty sure that rustam among
others have helped fabiano prepare in
this position i believe that black
white needs to decide where to put this
bishop on c1
uh one square is of course g5 that
really needs no explanation you're
pinning the knight
and often what you see in these
positions i've seen this a million times
is
as black tries to excommunicate the
bishop and of course the sacrifice on g5
needs to be very well evaluated
because you know the queen's going to
come out to f3 this is a super sharp
position i i actually still think this
is probably
theory uh and this has occurred and the
other way of developing is bishop b3 and
you might look at this and say wait a
second
you're just blundering upon but no if
you take a look at this knight it's
being
x-rayed by white's rope and with this
move g5
white basically wins a piece after
bishop takes you through rook takes e3
both knights
both nights are hanging and you can't
move one night and the best you can do
is
give up one of the knights for a pawn
but that is of course not satisfactory
compensation fiona so i think these two
moves among others
and bishop degree has just been played
bishop e3 has been played
and fabi well five actually if we look
at his clock times uh he's currently
been blitzing out uh all his moves
up two minutes from the starting time
and let's see
if bishop e3 comes as a surprise here
uh it seems to be going for his first
little thing of of the game but
sometimes the players are of course just
trying to remember the different lines
yeah i mean
believe it or not the top players are
humans and
it's not a great sign and i've shared a
couple stories from my game with fabi at
the 2017 u.s championship but
another one is that i i played the
french with black
i don't know what i was thinking i
played the french i really don't know
what i was thinking against baby of all
people he of course goes for the main
line
and i have done some good preparation
before the tournaments
and uh i mixed up the move order of one
of the main lines and
it wasn't the sort of mix up that's
forgivable i mean i'm basically losing
out of the opening
and the moment i mix up the move order
bobby
starts to think and i'm like oh no that
means thinking that means
i mean i've done something that's not
theoretical that means i'm probably
losing and i won't
i mean yesterday uh it's funny what he
was saying reminds me a little bit of
yesterday what we talked about this
insane game between uh fabiano and
young christophe duda and i have to say
it was really uh
so brave by duda you know he said
he knew if he entered if he played the
petrov he was probably entering
fabiano as a world championship match
crap but he said you know i was just too
curious and wanted to see what he had in
store there
which is incredibly brave yeah sometimes
you you just want to test yours
man this is such a solid opening what is
it that my opponent can do to me
but anyways here's the fascinating thing
fiona we have
three rye lopez's and i mentioned them
if we can quickly go to mbl against
anton and we will of course check into
magnus and the other interesting
matchups but just very quickly we
we do actually have a marshall in the
game between
mbl and davidonson and the marshall
is this move d5 i just mentioned that
while talking about hari hari's game and
i didn't know that
david anton had played it this is a
gambit
and it is a gamba that is named after
american player frank
james marshall who was a very very
interesting very combative chess player
i believe he played this against
uh former well world champion jose
capoblanca
uh the cuban genius and i actually think
marshall actually lost
the first game but um
he nonetheless did some analysis in this
line and the name bears
the line bears his name so black
sacrifices the pawn
actually maybe let me ask you a question
because i've never played the martial
from either side and
my understanding and just watching these
games from afar was always that
if both players know the world at the
line
super well that it often leads to a
forced
draw how correct is that that assessment
i think that's pretty correct i think
uh if you check correspondence chess and
we see very typical moves being played
here this is
a little bit odd that move rookie four
for example but it's actually quite
normal i mean the the rook
coming to h4 is quite normal
trying to smoke that queen out of h3 and
i think by and large fiona your
assessment is correct i think a lot of
top games do end in draws
because you know this has been first of
all so exhaustively analyzed
that um if you mentioned this in the
1970s
people would look at you and say what do
you mean marshall dry it's very
combative but now
you know black's activity usually
counterbalances
white's extra pawn i've had the marshall
several times from both sides i played
it once with black drop
uh ding liran played it against me with
black and
you know i was quite happy that he did
because i knew one of the the drawing
lines that i managed to make a draw
in a pro chessley game and i think i
faced it one more time that was also a
draw it's just
very very very exhaustively analyzed and
white keeps coming up with new ideas
black keeps analyzing them and it always
uh peters out somehow into a draw but we
will see if mbl has any new analysis uh
this move d3 by the way for those
interested in how the theory has
developed d4 has always been
the main line but uh i would say about
10 15 years ago players started
realizing that the move d3 has its
merits because this keeps the e4 square
defended and and that might not seem
significant
but if you imagine later in the game a
night appearing on e4 or even a rook
appearing on e4
uh that could be potentially important
fiona so
we will see how this plays out
absolutely and interesting shaping up to
be
an interesting game shouldn't we check
in with uh
with magnus carlsen on the black side
against europe magazine
i think too weak i don't think he
deserves to commentate his game
uh sure absolutely and another lopez
amazing
they're making up for the making up for
the
what's the the word something with d
yeah
is there a word like a derf yeah yeah
that's a good word dearth of jerusalem
the pasity of ray lopez is that's
another good word
the pulsar is best said in a british
accent the positive roy lopez is in
this tournament is quite appalling
actually speaking
of uh of british accents uh in uh
in not too long from now about 40
minutes from now we'll have
our first guest and it will be uh doctor
and grandmaster john nunn so maybe he
can maybe he can pronounce that for us
yeah certainly wouldn't presume to draw
even the british accent
that's incredible what's a guess yeah
john none is
absolute legend we'll we'll talk more
about him uh soon we will have another
legendary guest
coming later but we'll keep that a
surprise for
now let's take a look at what uh
variation of the rylopez9 displayed and
magnus
playing yet another uh sort of i think
this is called the molar
this should be seven so we have seen
two ways to develop the dark squidward
right uh davina and zone developing into
e7
and uh fabi developing it to c5 magnus
develops the other bishop first
and this line is sort of related to the
main lines and it's important to
recognize that knight g5 may come to
mind wait a minute isn't this winning
nope
uh black can play much like he does in
the pride liberty 5
he takes d5 and i believe either even 94
or 95
and uh the thing is black roots out this
bishop and that's no good for light once
the rye lopez bishop disappears
white's play really doesn't uh doesn't
go anywhere
and and so this has been proven to be
fine for black jordan instead focusing
on developing his pieces knight c3
a3 to create an escape square for his
bishop in the event of knight a5
but magnus going knight t4 sticking the
knight in the center
offering up a bomb uh jordan could have
accepted it but then after knight takes
b3 takes
something like d5 kind of like the
marshall fiona what that gets all this
counter play and white's pawn structure
is ruined
so jordan instead taking the knight and
we have this very interesting position
on
the board what are your thoughts about
what's transpiring so far
i think it's uh interesting that magnus
is choosing as
somewhat off the beaten uh track
uh line here against jordan's ray lopez
jordan who's very well prepared i think
it it makes sense to
to take an approach where um you know
you don't go for some absolute uh main
lines to test your opponent but
rather try to to get an off the beaten
track
position where magnus can try and
outplay uh jordan
you know in the middle game no
definitely the the molar is
far from being the main line it's you
know it's reputable it's not one of
those
crazy sidelines but but it definitely is
a sideline without a doubt
it's off the beaten path in the sense
that bishop b7 is quite a bit more
theoretical
and i think jordan jordan's moved d3 is
also not
quite the most i don't want to say
combative i think it's probably just as
good as the main lines but i believe
usually in the rylopas when you're
playing the main lines you play like
c3d4
that seems to be the most topical and um
jordan has shown that positionally and
and you know in these complex middle
games
i was also impressed with this game
yesterday against voitisha uh which a
game that kind of flew under the radar
but but hey you know jordan had
maybe a slightly worse middle game
roddick is an incredibly strong
positional player and he drew
the game from a position of strength i
mean he played
a flawless positional game
yeah an impressive start from jordan
who is still unbeaten in this uh this
year's tata steel and
certainly shaping up to be an
interesting game this one
absolutely so maybe i can run through
some of the key ideas
as i see it in the middle game now now
what we need to notice here
is the fact that the center is kind of
unbalanced and that just visually
is it is apparent and you know black's
pawns on c5 and d4 do look imposing
and black can contribute to his central
control by playing a timely d5 so
i think jordan has to deal with that and
he also has to deal with this knight on
e2 that knight is currently not very
employed so one idea that comes to mind
is knight to f4
just centralizing the knight and if uh
magnus plays d5 and jordan could meet
that with e5 and the knight is
pressuring
but i don't like this move as much
because it it blocks the development of
the bishop we've talked about
the dangers of that so the move i like
more is knight to g3
that is a very typical idea in the rye
lopez old as the hills
that knight potentially can access the
f5 square and if magnus playing d5 here
which he very well might
then i still think jordan could respond
with e5 let's say knight d7 and he could
support
this pawn with f4 the one concerning
thing fiona i think is after c4 bishop
a2 this bishop
is definitely out of the game for the
time being but yeah that doesn't mean
it's permanently
we can go to b1 and later that diagonal
can be opened
that does make sense i'm a little bit so
if
if with this idea that you're just
showing if the bishop goes back to
to b1 and then we play c3 do we not have
to
be concerned now there's no way black
can just entomb the bishop i guess
well black can trade this and then you
know the thing is
white actually and i know this is the
weird thing to say white doesn't always
need
all of his pieces to really generate
attacking chances so something like f5
here
and you can see him queen g4982 white's
got a lot of pieces that are in the game
and they can be enough to overpower uh
black's
king side because black's very well
protected i love the look on those pawns
on e5 and f5 yeah very appealing
yeah yeah i mean this is dangerous so
black can't fall asleep on on the king
side just because the bishop is
sort of bad for the time being yeah i
mean it's a
super rich position and then be
interesting to see which
which approach the players decide like
to go for
absolutely you know jordan can also
perhaps develop his bishop to g5 that's
certainly a viable alternative and we
will monitor how he
solves this opening problem but shall we
have a look at some of the other games
yeah let's maybe go to alireza furuja
who played such a brilliant game
yesterday and today
he's up against another youngsters both
of them are of
iranian descent ali ruiz are currently
playing for defeated flag while
arientari was born in norway
of course and always has represented
norway
absolutely and alireza choosing once
again one of his favorite recent
openings the
karo khan and uh we see the advanced car
with e5
and uh the bishop ii variation i think
this has happened
once before did uh magnus in his own
game
anyways i played this as black i said
against magnus um
right i think it was i maybe somebody
could remind us but i'm pretty sure i've
seen this
once before this tournament in
inaudible's game
uh i mean which is not surprising
because this line with bishop p2
is considered to be one of the most
testing
uh and popular systems against the
kernel actually i think it was
definitely against
what was it against mvl ah it might have
yes i think
you know this is very well studied and i
think aryan choosing a bit of a
different system
than mbl i think mvl kind of oriented
himself toward playing c4 at some point
where astari says all right i'm going to
defend the pawn on deep i'm going to
build up the pawn chain much like
you do kind of in the advanced french
and
then he plays his move 91. now this moon
91 is i've seen this idea before that
knight is
three shuffling to d3 and
why is this maneuver necessarily there's
a couple of things if the knight gets to
d3 first of all it's going to discourage
black from playing c5
black can certainly play c5 now and uh
that does come with its attendant
dangers you know it weakens this
diagonal and you know even g4 needs to
be considered here at some point that
bishop on f5 could get in trouble
in certain positions and sometimes this
trade is actually very beneficial for
white i can then
run his f-pawn straight down the middle
and uh it can be very hard to stop this
idea i actually think g4
is is a very legitimate threat a
positional threat in this position so
alireza has to come up with something
against that and the other thing is that
you know once that knight moves away
sometimes this bishop opens up and
you discourage black from sometimes
playing h5 you sometimes see this move
uh actually h5 may be interesting here
to stop g4 and if you take on h5
and i think queen h4 is going to create
very very nasty threats down the h-file
so
we'll see how alireza responds to this
but 91 is well within the bounds of
normality yeah i'm curious curious to
see what he does h5 certainly looks like
an interesting and interesting option
but ali raza he mentioned in an
interview that day against after the
draw against danville you know he loves
the carican
so we'll see we'll see what he comes up
with we certainly will and uh
as ali reza ponders his next move let's
have a look at some of the games that we
have not seen uh we have a couple of
night orbs actually side by side here
uh any preference and or should we have
a look at doodah geary maybe first
okay let's start with dudagiri and then
we'll then we'll get to the the knight
or
the knight orbs yeah and this one is
jose gruenfeld
and and it has the signature bishop on
g7 you can just tell open center
fiance bishop and one d4 a combination
of those things because gruenfeld and it
was indeed a grunfeld
but mvl is really known as the top group
specialist giri of course also an
opening
expert so this isn't a surprise choice
from him and we see here the main line
this is one of the most popular
variations of the greenfield one of the
oldest lines as well
and this move b6 i am not myself a
grunfeld
specialist full disclosure what i do
know is that the old school main line
used to be take stakes in bishop g4
which is very logical you're
indirectly applying pressure on the g4
upon you're inducing
this weakening move by three now black
counter attacks white bishop with night
a5
that used to be all the rage but
recently oh well relatively recently
people have started to play b6 and
essentially you just sacrifice the pawn
but and you do that in order to ruin
white's pawn structure to activate the
bishop and uh
in order to also get this e5 square for
black's knight which geary immediately
occupies i have seen this entire line
before
and i'm quite sure the black equalizes
here with best play but you have to
remember a lot
and if you get one thing wrong with
black you can end up down upon for no
compensation
i always find this so dangerous to go
for these you know
exercises and memorization to go for a
line that you're like
okay i have to be confident i remember
every single detail of this variation
and one wrong you know one wrong step
and i'm just a pawn down and i'm i'm
seriously worried
so but anisha me i mean nanish
is known for um for knowing his openings
very well so i'm confident but still a
risky risky approach
oh absolutely and and as we mentioned
these players sometimes they do confuse
lines it doesn't happen very often
because
the amount of time that they just spent
rehearsing their files reviewing
their analyses but it does happen and uh
what also should be mentioned is that
white has
it's not that white has one line that
you can go into white has
seven or eight different attempts all of
which are quite testing
and black has to know all of them you
have no idea which one your opponent is
going to choose
so actually well speaking of options
what are what are our options here
uh as white our knight is hit and this
central square is looking like the most
natural i guess yeah knight d4
looks natural but the issue here might
be the smoke queen c7 i'm not entirely
sure
uh but this creates of course this
pressure on the c3 pawn and after bishop
v4
i'm thinking that black can take a sort
of tame approach and just develop this
bishop to b7
uh this move a5 is very tempting you
might try to go after the c3 on the
issue here might be
the counter-attacking move knight to p5
hitting the queen and
defending c3 i'm sure this is also not
that bad for black
in fact uh jan kristoff has decided to
drop back to
a3 yeah so he's decided to leave the d4
square for the bishop which makes sense
because that square is a very very good
one the bishop is centralized and it
will protect
c3 and the knight yes knights on the rim
are dim
but uh that's not entirely true because
that knight can go back to c4
and try to dislodge its its vis-a-vis
on e5 so due to definitely trying to
consolidate here you said that black has
a very
narrow path having to remind remember
all the lines here
what is the idea for black is the idea
to try and get the pawn back as quickly
as possible or just go for active play
and get the pawn back in the longer
longer term i think it's the latter i
think it's it's
to go for active play and get the fine i
mean you wouldn't mind to get the pond
back you would accept it if offered
it's like you know i've eaten dinner but
if somebody offered me a burger i
probably wouldn't refuse it
but i think you know queen c7 to that
end is is sensible here
if white plays bishop e3 okay sure i'll
take the pawn white white's not gonna do
that white's gonna go bishop d4
but by and large i i think fiona yes the
idea is to go for activity which would
be seven and then maybe
put the rooks on on d8 and see it
activate all the pieces and
uh hope for full compensation for the
pawn maybe rook t at first
i'm not entirely sure uh this also makes
makes a lot of sense
let's uh let's come back to this one
let's see those two
night orbs we have uh we have today
uh let's do it so first we have
we have a dungeon co against erratic
voice check who is a perennial nadar
player
and a very interesting position that we
have on the board let's see how this
happened
h3 h3s8 by alexander
h3 of course i think this is sometimes
known as the bobby fischer variation
and it has been one of the most if not
the most popular line
i would say in the past five years too
on a white intense to expand on the
king's head with the muji
and would you say this is the sharpest
try against the night or
it is certainly i mean i think bishop g5
remains
extremely dynamic instead of h3 but it
definitely leads to
very very sharp positions especially the
line that roddick chooses
e5 and h5 which which may seem quite
radical
uh if that makes any sense but it is
actually i think the most popular
it is actually the most popular response
against this line because black simply
stops g4
this idea of playing juport is so
annoying that it is worth creating this
weakness on the king side
to prevent uh to prevent this move from
happening and uh we see
white instead playing g3 and kettling
the bishop this is all very normal
knight c5
centralizing tonight getting an outpost
and rook a7
another i would say a relatively typical
night of idea which which may seem weird
but
you are preparing to deploy the bishop
to b7
i'm curious because sorry you said that
until now everything sort of was
very standard but if we look at the
clock times radic has already spent
25 minutes so what was the move do you
think that came came as a surprise to
him
yeah my guess is maybe 95 because the
way that i've often seen this done
is i often see a4 played first and after
b4
then you go knight t5 but maybe in
alexander's preparation
you realize that the inclusion of these
two moves somehow favors black and one
way that that might be possible is that
as we see rook a7 bishop e3 chasing the
rook to b7 and g4 anyway
sacrificing upon in order to open oh
actually that's not even a sacrifice
because
if you attempt to simply take the pawn
myopically then queen 6b7 will win the
rook
so that rook is quite awkward and
alexander can
deploy his knight with knight 395. maybe
the inclusion of a4 in some lines
favors black and that might be what uh
radek is wrestling with
and such a sharp such a sharp position
and
i mean definitely a good sign for uh
for alexander that he has somewhere
managed to
to catch radoslav uh off off guard i
mean it's always so nice when you play a
game
and you manage to catch uh your opening
your opponent somewhere and somewhere
you surprise them and you get this
immediate you know half hour
up on the clock but what are what are
black's uh blank
options here after g4 yeah i just love
looking a little bit concerned um
well the zero v7 is what bothers me he's
actually just gone h4
uh so i'm there on camera yep so he's
trying to prevent
this knight from activating via g3
and uh what is alexander going to do i
mean if this is still his preparation
then i'm pretty sure he definitely
factored this move
factor this move in to his preparation
it does make sense
and i think that the key question for
white is which side is the castle and
i wouldn't rule out either queenside or
kingside gas because
one argument is that you want to castle
queenside so that you can open up the
king's side with that four
but the thing is if you cast a king side
that doesn't rule out the movement four
in fact it can make f4
even stronger for example let's say
black castle we play a four
after e takes up or knight takes up
board that rook is already poised
to wreak havoc along the f-file and uh
yes it is through the white's king is a
little bit weaker here
so you have to weigh the pros and cons
do a cost-benefit analysis
i think we're going to see alexander
either castle on one of the sides or
maybe play out four immediately
but this is very very sharp indeed
and this is one of the games today that
uh we're certainly gonna keep coming
back to
shaping up to be a very very exciting
dual shall we see
the other the other night or that we had
indeed we shall as pango against nils
grundelius
as nils attempting to bounce back after
that painful loss yesterday against
hari hari krishna and here we have a
more tame
uh night or the bishop is considered to
be
by many the relatively the quietest line
against the matter
because white uh intends only to castle
king side and that doesn't mean it's
quiet in the grand scheme of things it's
still a night or if it's still very very
full of life
but it was a favorite of anatoly karpov
and after e5 knight b3 bishop v6 here's
a very interesting thing fiona
um this move bishop e6
as far as i remember it's always been
considered an inaccuracy
uh due to f4 and queen c7 g4 has been
the main line since like the 70s but i
think niels
has analyzed this position in all of the
books you will find
that bishop e7 first is always the
recommended move bishop b6 is never
recommended
but that's the fascinating thing about
openings in the recent
recent day and age a lot of these things
are being redefined reconsidered
computers are breathing new life into
lines that were always considered bad
before and i mean it's also the beauty
of having
players like niels in this tournament
you mentioned you know he's such a
creative
player but i i'm struggling to
understand still i mean i
i'm not a night of player and i think
it's so tough to to understand the
different
nuances and the little details as to
what difference does it make especially
here i guess that white united white
didn't go
e4 f4 um can you explain or
sure what difference could it possibly
make yeah and
maybe somebody all right show me your id
what makes you qualified to explain that
well i did play the night or my whole
life basically until i was around 25 50.
so
i'm certainly nowhere near the level of
expertise of some
but i'll attempt to maybe explain some
of the key here so
i think what the what the game revolves
around is sort of the key factor
is this pawn on f4 and what happens to
it and one of the reasons that
uh the development of the bishop to e6
is frequently discouraged
is because white can play the move f5
with tempo
why is the move f5 particularly good
well the problem is it
attacks the bishop right now let's say
we just take the knight
if you notice this d5 squared that
square is really really weak
and you can imagine a reality in where
in which you know white can put a bishop
on c4 he can put a piece on d5
and then he can start attacking on the
king side with for example rook left a
lot of games have been lost
because black doesn't really have any
counter play you can just see how
passive black's position can be if he
can't break through with
the move t5 so that's i think one of the
key reasons that
this is often delayed and what is niels
possibly thinking here one of the things
that black has started doing
in response to the move f5 is this move
bishop d7
the bishop is redeployed to c6 and
basically black tries to break through
with d5
if black is successful in breaking
through with d5
then white's position can also collapse
very very quickly here so
i think that that's going to be the key
if white doesn't play f5
then black does sometimes take on f4 and
then use that e5 square
as a base of operation for for his
knight so one
very typical idea is to play e takes f4
and then knight c6 95 and that knight on
e5
is the pride of black's position so
several
factors here that might define uh the
next couple of moves
if huber i'll put you on the spot if you
were right here
what's your initial instinct what would
you go for i i would probably go for f5
i mean
and this might be like a duda syndrome
where i'm very curious what
exactly niels has prepared um but
you know f5 is definitely the principal
move but my secondary candidate would be
queenie one queen c3 which
you know which is a queen lift up to g3
in order to put pressure both
along the g pile and on the e5
so well this is another game where
yasipanko has taken a lot of time
compared to compared to his opponent
he doesn't seem like he's ready to make
a decision
just yet but certainly another game
um which is shaping i think today we're
spoiled once again oh yeah
absolutely some very combative lines
you're absolutely right isabenko
taking uh quite quite a lot of time here
which which makes sense because
you you know puns don't go backwards if
you play with like f5
and then you allow black to break
through with g5 why did i play at five
then you play if you play queen e1 and
maybe black takes on it ah
why didn't they play f5 so it's one of
those things i explained yesterday
you are going to regret whatever
decision you make uh and you know that
too that's the worst thing so you keep
trying to weigh
pros and cons you can't decide if it
happens he's actually he was actually
looking if you look at him on camera
there i know you have a couple of
seconds delayed it looked like he was
actually regretting his choice already
even
before making it and then he played
queen d3
okay so that's actually a similar move
to queenie one i i do think that he
is thinking about putting the queen on
g3 that's just a
you know he's taking the 485 rather than
77. he's taking one freeway rather than
another sorry not everybody will get
their reference those are
charlotte freeways yeah oh my god
you haven't heard of the freeways in
charlotte unacceptable
um i don't know if i would even manage
to place charlotte on the map actually
yeah i mean i wouldn't have either
before i moved there so i still might
not not be able to
in any case um queen d3 and
what is the benefit of putting the queen
on d3 versus e1 because
queenie one queen truth oops sorry i did
not mean to
click to the and i i think we may need
to
uh refresh one moment here um
so let's see if uh if i can get this to
work now so basically
oh uh just one moment my apologies
yeah actually maybe um maybe we're gonna
go on a very very quick uh break
uh in order to bring the board back so
we'll be back in just just a second
don't go anywhere
[Music]
and we're back with all the action from
uh round four and let's just jump
straight back into it you're just gonna
explain to us the differences
of the queen going to d3 or to e1
yeah i mean i think the queen is is you
know there might be no difference
it might transpose but ultimately the
queen is is supervising
uh the center i i brought up this story
of uh you know sometimes when you're in
time pressure and you need to go to the
bathroom
in an over the board chess game you do
this weird little dance where you're
you're getting up and you're looking
back at the board and you make sure you
take the path to the bathroom where you
can see the board all the way to the
bathroom so that if your opponent makes
a move you can run back to the board and
make
a response and this can be thought of in
that way the queen is sort of
supervising the center making sure
that a move like d5 something crazy like
this
is out of the question because here
after f takes e5 at the very least
uh and that's probably not even the best
move but that certainly does
does the job i mean now you just take on
e4 and you're up upon
if you had played queen e1 then i
actually do think that d5
uh would have would have been a
legitimate candidate move maybe not a
very good one but
something that would have needed to be
reckoned with because after f65 knight
takes c4
uh you know black restores material
equality and you get kind of an unclear
position
so that might be one reason um perhaps
there's others as well
in case white plays f5 the queen does
keep the d5 square under supervision
so uh it seems quite quite a subtle idea
but it's a big i kind of like this move
that's certainly a metaphor i won't be
forgetting the queen
being linked to a player trying to get a
bathroom back a break while long
time but let me keep d5 under control
yeah
anyways sorry that's a little out there
but hopefully it helps people see
understand the position better that's
ultimately the goal i'm sure it will
i'm sure it will um well magnum not
magnus niels is still considering his
options but
shall we go back to to magnus's game
yeah definitely lots of stuff
has happened in that game we had
observed the moment after c5 and jordan
deciding to develop his bishop first
which is sensible we had talked also
about knight g3
and we will see that move played in just
a second after d5 we have a mass trade
first jordan takes the knight on f6 to
soften up the d5 square
oh and we are back that was quick
apologies about that but
we are straight back with the magnus
game um and yeah the piece is coming off
the board
yeah and i think what i was explaining
is that this e4 square can be covered by
a pawn that lands on f5 so one idea is
to play bishop e5
and if you just sort of play knight e4
and say well look at my knight my knight
is awesome
no it's not get out of there f5 and that
knight is chased away so that actually
can get very dangerous for white
if jordan doesn't find a way to kind of
establish his pieces in the center
his position can get very cramped and uh
to that effect i think magnus can can
play bishop b5 he doesn't have to rush
with that
that would be a very magnus-like
decision
just very calmly waiting for jordan to
play 94 and then playing the 55
but in the events of something like this
then jordan could go queen f3 for
example
and uh control that square and perhaps
also
then threatening this knight f6 check
x-ray so
this is an important decision for magnus
and you're going to have a very classic
battle between knight and bishop which
piece is going to be stronger
i like magnus's position here i think
he's got a little more space
he's got a good pawn structure but i
really i think the position is equal and
i think jordan is doing a good job
of uh really sort of you know getting
kind of composition where
uh magnus could start getting frustrated
that he doesn't have quite the kind of
winning chances that he might like
to have yeah i'm curious uh
curious to see where the piece is and
what do you think is the ideal piece
placement for
for both sides here yeah i mean the real
question is does
you know when does dwight want to play
an 84 because you don't want to rush
this move as i
as i explained another idea is to play
the move g6 or maybe the bishop should
be
being carried and and tucked away safely
and another idea of course is 94 bishop
and once again
black is ready to play f5 now and chase
away the knight so jordan doesn't want
to rush with that
uh so maybe you want to keep the knight
on g3 for the time being
another key question is do we want the
queens off the board if you're jordan if
you're magnus i don't think it's worth
going queen f3
and ruining your pawn structure in order
to trade queens but you know that that's
not out of the question
uh because there's really nothing to
exploit this pawn structure with black
is slightly better here
but it might not be enough to win the
game so
and the third question is does magnus
want to play the move c4 at some point
and expand
his queen side on pressure that move
doesn't really accomplish
anything in and of itself but maybe it's
part of
a series of moves that puts pressure on
white's position very interesting
position uh it may look very simple but
there's a lot of decisions
to be made for both both sides here i
mean certainly
far from simple in general but
especially not when you're playing
against magnus and magnus who was left
you know slightly frustrated yesterday i
think after his game against zaria and
tyree where
uh a lot of pieces came off the board
early uh
early on and although magnus was pushing
ever so slightly it just wasn't enough
and magnus has indeed gone uh c4 so
he has decided to expand that pressure
on the queen side
and put some heat on white's d3 pawn now
jordan
certainly does not want to take this
pawn because that would uh that would
move that
key uh defender from the e4 square it
wouldn't it would deprive the knight of
its natural placement
jordan has a couple of moves here queen
g4 comes to mind just activating the
queen
of course that old move knight e4 we
talked about should certainly be
considered and maybe jordan wants to
play something like rookie one
sort of procrastinating uh in a good way
improving a piece and
seeing how magus just decides to arrange
his pieces i have a question if we go
queen g1 are we
kind of threatening to play knight h5
oh yeah i think we definitely are uh
just for example let's say black
improves the position of his rook we can
go in at h5
and uh well this threatens knight takes
f6 because of the pin
and efficient p5 i think you intended to
move f4
and that's definitely quite unpleasant
for black black and saved the bishop by
playing
f5 and then dropping the bishop back to
upstate so that the rook
protects that bishop but this is
definitely probably going to bail out
and that's not what magnus wants so
certainly that's that's an idea
actually if the bishop and the knight
were to to come off the board do you
think magnus
would still have a little something as
his pawns are more advanced or do you
think it would just be
even that's a good question i'm not
entirely sure i think magnus maybe has a
tiny something so for example queen g3
bishop has to drop back and see if i
were jordan i wouldn't take on f6 here
that bishop
isn't going anywhere i would play the
move rook at e1
and try to wrest control of the e file
from
from white one of the common mistakes
that's often committed in these kinds of
positions is you just assume ah to draw
what you want and then what happens is
black will play rook after e6 he's like
no
no no i'm not giving you the e-file and
now you can't play rookie one and now
ideas like queenie two or queen e3 check
become very very unpleasant so these
games
that seem very drawish are often lost
because one side loses control of a key
file
yeah this already i wouldn't wanna i
wouldn't wanna be white here
but yeah certainly uh a lot of
things to to consider here for you and i
like your suggestion though of queen g4
because i also feel it's about time i
linked
linked my works um and and got the queen
out
i'm actually i'm struggling to even
think of
of other moves right now yeah i mean
queen g4 certainly is supernatural um
well not supernatural in the sense of
ghostly
uh or magical but it is it is very or
extremely natural uh but rookie one i
think is is also
a sensible move and 94 should also be
considered
uh but i i do i am leaning toward queen
g4
the one problem that i will mention and
this is a little bit maybe i'm going a
little too deep but
if black does play this move g6 that i
had mentioned and then drops his bishop
back to g7 one problem
is that this queen on g4 could actually
get caught in the crosshairs of this
move f5 that move could come with tempo
and you certainly don't want magnus to
gain all control of the
e4 squad with tempo so maybe that is
something jordan has to factor in i
don't think it's a deal breaker per se
but it is it is a factor that you know
that jordan should definitely
consider while making his decision and
he's taking his time here this is
a complicated moment for sure absolutely
let's leave
jordan to it for now we'll come back to
it
uh can we check in what was that that um
lidor was it the grandest game or
um well grandelias is well there's it's
a penguin delias
and uh cepanko is
these are our two our two darlings our
two night off games let's check in on
the other one don't
go against voice check this is
definitely a sharper night off and we
joined
uh we had seen this moment right when
roddick had gone page
four and uh responds by donating a very
very sharp f4 uh just trying to open up
that f-file
and the one thing that we mentioned is
he's got to decide where to put his king
and for the time being
keeps his king in the center uh which is
which is sensible but i think at some
point and perhaps that moment
has arrived he has to decide which way
he castles
my inclination i don't actually know i
mean castling is short i really like the
fact
that this gains control of the file but
certainly a big decision here
to be made by alexander
yeah a lot to consider he also he spent
20 minutes
since we last left him just on that one
move f4 and now
considering his next option uh so we
will leave him to it as well we're
actually going to take
just a very very short break to set up
our first
guest of the day i'm very much looking
forward to
having doctor and grandmaster john nunn
with us in just a second so
don't go anywhere and we'll be right
back with him
[Music]
welcome back and i'm absolutely
delighted to be joined by a very special
guest
grandmaster and dr john nunn uh john
welcome to the show it's an absolute
pleasure having you well thanks very
much fiona it's
nice to be joining your show this
afternoon
maybe just a quick introduction uh
seeing as
you know there's been so many new people
coming to the game
uh this year who might not be familiar
with all the all the things
you achieved in chess and in uh
in numerous other fields so john is a
three-time
world champion in chess problem solving
we'll talk about that in a sec he's a
very prolific chess writer
and you're also one of the youngest
graduates in oxford i'll get to all that
in a second it's a lot to touch upon
but let's we have to talk first about
john you played here in vikanze you
played here
seven times and you won it three times
in 1982 in 1990 and in 1991
so maybe my first question to you is
what memories do you have of playing
here
in vikenzi i always enjoyed playing
vikrante
you know it's always been a very
friendly tournament and
of course if you have success on the
board it does
create a favor of an impression but even
despite that even the years when i
didn't play so well
i still had a good time and i always
looked forward to coming again the year
after
and as you say i won three times once
once jointly in 1982 and twice outright
and yeah great times in those days
well i can i can only imagine and uh
let's maybe especially talk about the
achievement of winning it back to back
which
only very few players have apologies
about that hopefully hopefully we'll be
all right now
uh john my apologies to you as well and
welcome back once again grandmaster
john none with us john i was just uh
saying you won the tournament
back to back which only very few players
have achieved in the history
of the tournament do you have any
special memories of that
yes i mean it was uh certainly a great
chess festival and of course it was not
only the grand master tournament but
there were lots of other events as well
for for masters and for club players and
i often met you know dutch players there
every year who come and play one of the
lower tournaments and
it was always fun to chat to the chess
enthusiasts of all levels
and excited a huge amount of public
interest and of course it still does
today
i think one of the things that strikes
me about you know this
icons hundred tournament is the large
amount of public interest
big reports in newspapers now of course
we have internet and
video which you're heavily involved in
um
but it's it's not only the chess it's
also the way it's brought to a wide
audience
that struck me as being a particular
feature of this event
yeah i think it really you know if i can
say throughout the years always have
been such a big festival
as you say so many locals getting
involved coming by it's free entry
everyone
can join in on the fun and see these you
know best players in the world
from so so close up this year
unfortunately
the event had to be very different with
only only the 14 masters no spectators
no amateurs no challenger groups
um have you been following the
tournament yes i've been following the
tournament um
so it kind of mixed back some very
interesting games
obviously karana's game yesterday was
fascinating
um good positional game yesterday by
harry krishna i thought
um so yeah always a crop of interesting
games and
maybe also in previous years there was
always a big
side event here i if i recall correctly
there was always a big
chess problem solving competition did
you ever come
to vikanzi for that rather than for the
main event
in recent years yes several years ago i
came for the
uh study solving competition which was
held and always on the final weekend
and i think i won it twice
um but i didn't play you know it was
after my kind of retirement as it were
well i still play a little bit even
today at the moment it's all online of
course
um but when i retired from playing
professionally again i enjoyed watching
the tournament and i took part in the
solving competition actually how do you
balance the many
interests that you have these days so
you're still into
problem solving i know that you
are very passionate about astronomy
you're a prolific
author you have what it so many jazz
books so how do you
how do you balance all these things well
it makes for a busy life of course
but um yeah i think i'm probably more
heavily involved in problem solving
right now
than playing chess um
well age is a factor but um i'm
currently actually the british problem
solving champion
oh wow something you can do even when
you're in your mid 60s
whereas that over-the-board chest
becomes i think quite difficult once you
start to approach 50 although of course
you know players like
vichy have continued to have an active
career for quite a long time
and i just have a last couple of
questions for you before we
before we let you go uh one of the other
things you're also still active in as a
writing chess books do you have
any new books uh in coming up
well i've just released a book called
the chess in-game exercise book
which um you know is for so we say good
club players
um it's setting selling very well
and it's a whole book of training
exercises for the end game
um of course as the author i'm
definitely going to recommend it
i'm sure that would be very useful for a
lot of our views so go get your hands on
it and john
uh just the last question for me i think
one of the most
interesting things um about all your
achievements
is you actually graduated
um from oxford college uh
well at 15 at 15 years of age you were
oxford's youngest undergraduates it's
kind of
since cardinal wolsey in 1520
so you know something about uh what it
is
to be you know a child prodigy and i i
wanted to
ask you on your thoughts about ali
zafiruja who these days you know he's
the
the child prodigy i think of the chess
world so what are your thoughts
on ali raza well he's obviously an
incredibly talented player i mean
a lot of success and you know a bright
career ahead of him
but one thing i should say is that i was
considered a child prodigy and then the
years passed and then suddenly without
any warning it seemed i was the oldest
player in the tournament
so it doesn't last forever enjoy it
while you can
actually there's one last thing that's
just secure to me now
i remember i'd forgotten about this but
i remember reading that magnus carlsen
actually said about you
in an interview that the reason you
didn't become
a world champion it's because you were
too smart for
for your own good and too many interests
so what did you make of magnus's
assessment well he's a very polite man
john we'll end it we'll end it on that
thank you
so very much for your time it was an
absolute
pleasure uh having you and i hope we'll
have you back here in vaikanji on site
in the coming years sure thank you very
much
thank you have a nice day and we'll be
back with dania in just a second
[Music]
and welcome back welcome back dania
it's great having you back but it was
also so great having uh
john none on the show i mean such an
accomplished man but so nice so humble
and it was a great
great to hear it from him but let's go
back to the games now a lot of action
here in round four
indeed indeed there is and uh really i
mean
he's just such a legend i mean so
multifaceted so many achievements from
books to
puzzle solving genius astronomy
photography
i mean a true renaissance man in in the
best possible way and
that was that was awesome and uh i think
you conducted that great so let's let's
jump back into the games though
um any game that you'd like to start
with a particular fiona anything
catching your eye
well let's i saw you hover for a second
over the magnus game do we have a couple
more pieces
coming off the board there so after c4
jordan did indeed so rookie one was one
of the two moves that um
was one of the two moves that we had
mentioned just sort of improving the
position magnus
responding in kind with the move rook a
to e8
and now jordan going a4 and basically
what he's done is he's waited for black
to
get off of the eight file and now of
course because he's got a rook on a1
opening up the a file is kind of in his
favor
um and and also that leads to more
trades and you know you heard and
certainly wouldn't mind a draw magnus
does trade
on e1 and magnus has just taken on d3 so
rapidly we see a lot of pieces coming
off the board
what i think magnus wants to do here is
perhaps go queen to b3
and actually try to go go after these
pawns so this is no lag